what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again with the
latest full translator one piece manga
chapter and it is amazing i just did a
poll yesterday on the anime outpour
instagram about who would win in a fight
shanks vs sakazuki and last time i
checked percent of people voted for
shanks and the hype for shanks is only
gonna grow after this insane chapter so
make sure to stay tuned for this one
chella parking with it and smash that
like button if you enjoy these one-piece
reviews be a smashing pirate king and
not a passing orochi and youtube will
reward you with wano fireworks true
story enjoy the fireworks because the
passing orochis will never experience
that thrill and if you haven't make this
the video you joined the knock one by
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece reviews and updates now i want
to thank today's awesome sponsor
hellofresh you can now go to
hellofresh.com and use
codeanimeoper16 for 16 free meals across
7 boxes and three free gifts the beauty
of hellofresh is that it delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week so you don't
have to waste your time at grocery
stores which is a huge plus for me their
recipes are delicious and hello fresh
allows you to save not only time but
money as well and i love saving money in
fact hello fresh is up to 72 percent
cheaper than dining at a restaurant and
as an added bonus hellofresh's
streamlined supply chain reduces
greenhouse gas emissions compared to
grocery shopping plus in partnership
with plastic bank hellofresh prevents 10
million bottles from entering the ocean
every year so you have every reason to
feel good about eating with hellofresh
my friend and i made chicken ranch wraps
with cheddar and golden potato coins the
other day and they were delicious what i
found out i really liked about
hellofresh was the sense of
accomplishment you get when you prepare
a wholesome delicious meal for yourself
i am like the furthest thing from a cook
and yet we had a blast making and eating
these wraps hellofresh's foolproof
step-by-step recipes writing in around
30 minutes or less made that possible
for me and if i can do it anyone can do
it so what are you waiting for go to
hellofresh.com and use code anime uproar
16 for 16 free meals across 7 boxes and
3 free gifts and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all
this chapter is called new age and it
starts with the wano party still in full
swing we see nami and zeus having a
great time with tama obviously green
bull hasn't rained on their parade yet
but let's see if momo can keep it that
way as you'll remember momo yamato and
the scabbards confronted greenville last
chapter their plan was to make sure the
people of wano can enjoy their liberty
by stopping the admiral in his tracks
and even though forest logia green bull
had the upper hand dragon momo was
telling yamato not to interfere we catch
up to them here and as greenville and
his broccoli head smash momo into the
ground rizzo launches fire release at
greenville if you know your pokemon you
know that fire type is super effective
against plant slash grass type and for
you non-pokemon fans i guess it should
also make sense that fire is not good
for a forest green bill acts like he's
in pain which seems to be his thing he's
not very stoic and he often expresses
pain even when like this time he's just
kidding he says he's a fireproof forest
he mentions they're going up against an
admiral and they really think he
wouldn't be able to guard against such
an obvious weakness this obviously does
make sense since kaido pointed out
fruits are not a big deal and many of
the best don't even have fruits so
there's no way a skilled admiral would
lose just because his fruit may be weak
against an attack type according to
pokemon rules he launches one of his
roots at rhizo and starts sapping his
nutrients as he did with king and queen
meanwhile the other scabbards are having
trouble too kamatsu notes how the roots
keep coming no matter how much they cut
them in a way green bowl seems to be
like marco he can regenerate as long as
his stamina lasts and from what we've
seen he's nowhere close to running out
of stamina eventually denjiro kawamatsu
and nekomamushi are shown getting
trapped by the vines man the red
scabbards do not have the best record
for doing well in fights recently albeit
they've been up against powerful
opponents but still this isn't making
them look any better we'll get a
conclusion to this fight soon but first
we go to the castle basement aka
sukiyaki secret room robin sukiyaki and
law are making their way down some
stairs after being told he sniffed them
out well law says he's not a hyena he
just noticed that the two were missing
so he came wondering what they were up
to and i gotta say law given his
interest in history and the truth of the
world is the perfect person to tag along
here sukiyaki says he never told kaido
about this but they found the ponoglyph
because of all star jack since he's a
fisherman at first robin is like why
would being a fisherman help but
sukiyaki just says they'll see soon when
law asks how much deeper down are they
going to go sukiyaki says a few hundred
years deeper so the mystery keeps
building here through a crawl space they
finally see what's going on they are
below sea level and like the city of
atlantis they see what looks like under
the siwano sukiyaki points out it's an
older wano from 800 years ago again we
get that magic 800 number sukiyaki says
he doesn't know what ended up happening
but also goes on to say that wano used
to be larger and located at sea level on
the land around the base of mount fuji
and since we have a mount fuji all this
is kind of giving me a planet of the
apes vibes but we'll see what happens
i'm sure the one piece probably won't be
the statue of liberty but anyways at
some point the walls were erected all
around enclosing the island as a result
the rainwater had nowhere to escape to
and whole towns were eventually
submerged and abandoned people moved
further up the mountain and knew wano
the one we know came to be finally they
arrived to the road poneglyph robin
points out that this is their third and
they just need one more to travel to
laughtale then sukiyaki gives us the
vague location of pluton he says it's
lower down but he's never seen it
himself apparently retrieving pluton
would require the removal of the walls
that surround wanom thus opening the
country also is a literal act they would
lose their greatest defense and set
loose one of the ancient weapons but you
know what they say sometimes the best
defense is a good offense and i feel
like if wano had pluton it would more
than make up for the lack of walls but
again we don't have all the pieces here
so it's hard to say we do know that
crocodile was so confident in the might
of pluton that he felt like it would let
him build a nation more powerful than
the world government and that they
couldn't do anything about it because
he'd have pluton so if the legends are
true it would be a game changer for
anyone who could acquire and use it when
robin asks if opening the country
unleashes bluton why would odin want
that sukiyaki explains he doesn't know
he only knows what's been passed down
not about what odin experienced during
his voyages outside however i do think
part of it is that all the ancient
weapons will have to be present for
luffy the new era joyboy to achieve his
destiny which is likely liberating the
world from a corrupt world government
and preventing an even worse power like
blackbeard from taking over now let's
get back to the admiral greenball fight
and let's just say it greenville hasn't
been too impressive since crushing king
and queen effortlessly but again they
were in recovery from their defeats at
the hands of the straw hats now he's
having trouble getting past yamato momo
and the scabbards like whatever you say
it's clearly taking him time and he's
evidently ticked off and when someone
can easily overpower people he usually
doesn't get ticked off he just does it
don't get me wrong i'm sure he's strong
but he's just not giving off the vibes
we might have expected a few chapters
ago he continues to talk about how he's
nature and no man can hope to stand
against nature he says if kaido was in
charge he wouldn't have come back
although he's sure his regime was
miserable he also knows he imposed order
that served to deter other predators
from targeting the country we're getting
more of his philosophical views here and
he has a point beating a strong ruler
does leave the country vulnerable to
external attack especially since luffy
the man who beat him is gonna leave then
he drops the philosophy and is just like
okay bring me luffy and i'll leave he's
shown holding and clearly overpowering
the scabbards with his roots like i said
they really did not accomplish anything
during this fight yamato is again like
let's call luffy and the gang to show
aramaki what's up but momo says no and
finally explains why he's been telling
yamato not to interfere and it's the
same reason that i suggested in the
prior chapter review since yamato has a
chance to be free and leave luano momo's
all for it however it will mean that
yamato will no longer stay behind to
defend wano and so the ones who will
stand behind have to take over they have
to prove that they can repel the enemy
on their own otherwise and this is a
great point how can they look at those
who leave and say that wano is safe with
them who stay again there's that focus
on yamato and momo and again i'm here
hoping yamato doesn't have a change of
heart about joining the straw hats in
order to stay in guardwano i'm
especially worried about this because of
the whole having a guardian deity of
wano fruit so i can't really accept
yamato as a straw hat until yamato
leaves the island with them and i'm
really hoping for that yamato is touched
by momo and then we turn back to momo vs
demon tree as he calls aramaki aramaki
insults him remarking that even dragons
can be pathetic but then momo tells him
to leave again and this time aramaki
shows genuine panic momo actually pulls
off a bowl of breath that really seems
to hurt aramaki at least the attack
creates a huge hole in his tree body
this attack also affects aramaki enough
that he releases the scabbards denjiro
even compliments momo saying his attack
was the spitting image of kaidos aramaki
is mad now but momo launches another
bowl of breath aramaki tells him to hang
on but then he's blown away yamato is
amazed too but does point out that
momo's aim leaves much to be desired
aramaki looks to be in excruciating pain
as the flames engulf him eventually it
seems like momo burned everything so
greenville has to sprout again from a
single small clover looking thing now i
think aramaki is fine for now but again
i feel like he couldn't do this forever
there must be a point where he can no
longer regenerate into a new body but he
definitely have to hit that limit with a
stronger opponent just as aramaki is
supposedly gonna show how strong he is
and defeat momo and the others black
lightning is seen from a distance and
now that black lightning brings us to
the most hyped part of this chapter
green bull looks to be paralyzed and in
pain again he says wait that conquers
hockey who the the red hair pirates
you're here too end quote we see what
looks like sweat coming from him and his
hands shoot up as if in surrender we
then catch up to see what's happening on
the red hair pirates ship they tell
shanks not to go all out with this
hockey like that since the newbies are
all foaming from the mouth then shanks
goes on to talk as if he's talking right
to greenville and whether greenville is
getting the words or the emotions that
shanks is sending it's clear that
shanks's thoughts are getting to and
being understood by greenville despite
their distance shanks says i won't call
you marines cowardly or underhanded for
this but wouldn't you agree it's bad
form to go after these worn out saplings
when they're exhausted from making
pirate history end quote and i totally
agree with shanks here that's totally
bad form but then again the world
government has never been one for good
form so we then see some of shanks's
memories like luffy's cut a time momo
injured his head and so on we see hiri
and what some have called a silhouette
of shanks's daughter from the new movie
there was a whole movie bonus page about
her creating a song for the new era as
well so it makes sense that she'd be
tied to it especially in shanks's mind
we then see shanks really angry which is
hype because we don't see that side of
shanks often i can't even remember if we
ever saw him this angry he says does the
new age frighten you that much and
finally greenville's like i get it
already it's not like i want to pick a
fight with you guys not today anyways
and so the green ball being
underwhelming compared to his initial
debut continues he served to hype up
shanks further a character we all love
and further more love to see hyped up
shakes is really something being able to
have this kind of effect on an admiral
from a distance by just letting out some
hockey this dude's sway over others
especially over enemies must be the
greatest we've seen so far dude stopped
kaido the paramount war and now green
bull without even getting close i love
to see it and i can't wait to see this
guy actually participate in a real fight
hilariously enough from the perspective
of yamato and momo it probably seems
like green bowl was talking about them
like momo's attacks got aramaki to say
he doesn't want to pick a fight so
they're celebrating and momo even starts
crying and so wraps up the not so crazy
green bull approaching the wano party
saga it wasn't battle to the death all
it took was shanks just being like leave
bro and aramaki being like oh okay okay
sorry we then returned to the party and
we see that luffy zoro sanji and jinbe
were watching the fight aramaki is gone
and zoro even says check momo out they
are clearly proud of him and his solid
attacks they were on standby ready to
help if things got ugly jimby is the one
to first comment on the haki and says
how it was something else luffy says
yeah who was that a familiar face just
popped into my head he says while
smiling so although luffy sends shanks
and he probably saw shanks's face pop
into his mind he still isn't sure what
happened but at least shanks did serve a
purpose and it wasn't just a pointless
tease he did stop adamaki from perhaps
seriously injuring some straw hats so
hey i guess we can't complain and say
that he had no purpose being so close to
luffy if he wasn't gonna make contact
but i will say clearly luffy is a great
pirate by now so a meetup would have
definitely been justified lastly we see
the red hair ship drifting in the vast
ocean and that wraps it up let me know
your thoughts on the full chapter when
are luffy and shanks finally gonna meet
if not now and will blackbeard meet with
shanks sooner as i expect he will either
way it's exciting stuff and as the title
suggests this wraps up wano for me with
a green ball leaving and now we move on
to a new age of one piece one where
we'll hopefully get to see more of
shanks now chill the pirate king within
and smash that like button if you enjoy
these one-piece reviews be a smashing
pirate king and never a passing odochie
and youtube will reward you with wano
fireworks true story click that like
button and experience the thrill that
passing orochi's never will and if you
haven't make this the video you join the
knockout by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one-piece reviews and updates and if
you're a real one and made it all the
way to the end of this video drop a
hashtag angry shanks in the comments to
let me know thank you so much i really
appreciate it lastly while you wait for
future videos and updates to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
from all the yonko warlords admirals and
much more link to that is in the
description and on screen right now and
until next time see ya space cowboys